Yan Nai has just made a big blunder and
honestly it's a bit of a strange mistake
for for Yan to make because this is a a
very known Motif which occurs in a lot
of openings actually the idea of first
bringing the G7 Pawn out you destroy a
little bit of Black's queen king Side by
creating the sacrifice and then you take
on E6 and this forces another Pawn out
of the way and this gives you this queen
G6 check uh this exists in the pets
there is a lot of very famous position
in the pet where this happens is got an
expression like okay let's make a draw
like okay this is a perpet this is not a
Perpetual no way no super instructive
Stu when he gets the final piece into
the attack he brings the Rook from A1
takes the time out to join the party
bring all the toys to the nursery and
now there's a massive threat of The Rook
jumping onto the center of the board on
E5 toys to the nursery I it's a nursery
you want to be at right now this is
looking uh like a big attack